today we're going to be working on some
problems to do with measurement and
composite figures now if you're the kind
of person who really likes to just get
stuck into the mathematics right away
then feel free to use the time codes in
the description or the chapters and Skip
Along to where we begin actually having
a look at the problems but for everyone
else I'm actually going to give a little
bit of a preamble a prologue to what
these questions are where they came from
and also some of the thinking behind it
because you might be interested in some
of that especially if you're a
mathematics teacher and I know there's a
bunch of you out there who are watching
so for starters where do these questions
come from well I actually created these
questions myself many years ago this
says 2009 here so more than 10 more than
a decade ago at a previous school and
the reason why I created this worksheet
as it were is because often teachers
will rely on you know things they find
on the internet or textbooks but it's
often the case that we won't find
exactly the questions that we're after
or we'll find like one nice question
here and another one there but not in
the same place and one of the most
important things that all teachers do is
we change the way that we teach in
response to what exactly our students
need so I put together this sheet for
the purpose of a particular class that I
was teaching can't remember even what
grade it was that's how long ago that I
taught this particular I created this
particular worksheet and taught that
particular class one of the things that
is tricky though is that years and years
ago I made this worksheet available on
my website so that other teachers and
students could grab a hold of it but one
of the tricky things that happens is
that you know when I use this worksheet
in my class I don't just hand the
worksheet out and just say Okay off you
go I actually interact with my students
I have a plan for how I will use this
worksheet and and sort of question and
prompt and support my students to work
through these questions and often I will
actually have a plan in my mind for a
particular question and how it's
designed to prompt conversation or
discussion or questioning and that's the
case with some of these questions and so
if you just
picked up this worksheet you just
downloaded it off my website and I'll
put the link down below so you can get
hold of it and print it if you want
as you were looking through it you might
have gotten a little bit confused at
some of the questions because my
explanation in the classroom wasn't part
of the worksheet experience so for most
of these questions what you'll find is
they're they're fairly straightforward
and what I've done is I've already you
know written up some answers here that I
will very briefly walk through and
explain each of the the thinking behind
it but then there are a couple of
questions kind of scattered throughout
this worksheet and it's design that
actually raised a few more questions and
they were intended in my class to make
students think a little bit they're what
we call a non-routine problem it raises
uh challenges that it's not quite
obvious what to do with them there's not
just a straightforward formula or
algorithm you actually have to do a
slightly bit of creative problem solving
as you're going about it so we'll
encounter those questions as we go
there are six questions on this sheet
and they're all about uh area and
perimeter for composite figures and as I
so helpfully wrote more than 10 years
ago composite figures are composed
that's the composite part of the basic
figures so you know triangle Circle
squares rectangles and all the rest
so that's where you can see where these
come from they aren't too complex in
terms of the different designs behind
them but what we're going to do is have
a look at um each one in turn and I'll
work you through the solutions and the
thinking behind them okay now it is
important to recognize why do we care
about this at all one of the best
examples that I can find of composite
figures in reality is just the world
that we live in this for example is a
satellite a photograph of my school and
if you just have a quick look here right
even though most of the buildings these
are the original buildings over here
they're just Square so it's not too
difficult to work out what's say for
example the area of the roof is there's
a new block over here it only opened a
couple of years ago and it's a weird
looking shape over there it's not a
rectangle or a parallelogram or it's
just composed of many different pieces
together so if for example you wanted to
know the area of that roof which would
be important to know how many materials
you need and all the rest you're going
to have to create that as a composite
figure and in fact there are other
composite figures tucked away in here if
you look closely here
see if I can outline it for you this is
the playground that I'm now going to try
and draw for you let's choose a nice
bright color like this so here why am I
dotted I don't need to be dotted uh yeah
that'll do here is the outline of the
playground and a grassed area and you
might be wondering why is this so curvy
well actually it is called that area
it's called the serpentine wall and it's
actually a an Australian First Nations
symbol a snake is a really big part the
rainbow serpent is a big part of their
creation myth and other things as well
so you can see you've got this kind of
outline here and this area very roughly
speaking is all intended to be grassed
so if you were trying to work out the
area of the grass to say for example
work out how much water and fertilizer
it needed then again guess what
composite figure so these kinds of
shapes happen all the time in fact
rectangles circles triangles perfect
shapes happen surprisingly infrequently
in nature so composite figures are
absolutely worth wrestling with and
wrapping your head around
so with no further Ado let's actually
have a look at some of the questions and
as I stated before for the questions
that are pretty straightforward we will
just have a look at my my pre-done
working I'll just highlight a few bits
and pieces here and there but then when
we encounter some of the more tricky
ones we'll actually work through it bit
by bit
so here is the first question you can
see I've already put a bit of working
onto the diagram here all that you get
provided is the fact that this is two
centimeters you've got these lengths
here that are all equal and then you've
got a right angle here and the rest you
need to infer so you can probably tell
already this is going to be a square so
it's just two by two and that's where
you get this area one over here and then
this second area over here you can treat
it as just a separate triangle and do
half base times height if you like but
half base times height comes from the
fact that this triangle here is com is
made up of half of the area of the
rectangle around it which is this Square
A1 if you were to uh you know draw that
all the way around if I were to do some
dots over here you can recognize that
that whole outline is just the entirety
of A1 and I've just sliced it in half so
that's where I got this and you can see
by the way through my working I've done
all the areas in purple and all of the
perimeters in Orange just so it's a bit
easier to distinguish
then when you go around the same lengths
that I mentioned here before p q q r r s
and s t all of them are two centimeters
in length so I just multiply that by
four to get the eight and then you need
to use Pythagoras I haven't stated it
here but PT is the hypotenuse of this
PST triangle so that's where Pythagoras
Theorem comes in here that's the exact
length eight plus root eight but so that
we could do a bit of a sense check I
thought it'd be helpful to just do a bit
of an approximation there and that's
just to Judson places 10.83 centimeters
and we're done
all right question two here there's a
nice little Archway which is composed of
a semi circle across the top and then
you've got this rectangle that's
attached to it underneath so again I've
just given some names here area one is
this rectangle area two is the
semi-circle and so I've just done length
times breadth over here and then when it
comes to the semi-circle I've got half
times pi times the radius square and you
just have to watch for the fact that 10
across here is the diameter so I had to
halve that to get the radius
that gives me this area once I uh
approximate out and get Pi out of the
way and then when working the perimeter
the really the only tricky part here is
uh that half of the circumference so I'm
using half times pi times the diameter
that's actually the definition of pi
it's the ratio between the diameter and
the circumference and I did half because
it's a semicircle
after that you can see I've got this 10
down here and the 2 times 4 comes from
those two vertical edges over there and
33.71 is where I ended up